when I first started cooking
professionally pretty much all the
high-end British restaurants serve very
rich French inspired food lots of
sources lots of cream and butter service
but what I've tried to do in my rations
is keep the finesse and flavor but make
my food much much lighter and I've done
the same thing at home too so for my
ultimate light lunch I'm using lots of
raw ingredients herbs and citrus flavors
mackerel ceviche with the most amazing
crisp delicious fennel salad mackerel
it's incredible
cheap was so delicious as you fish a
just means basically marinating but the
secret is in the dressing been great for
take the top off and the bottom and
don't slice off too much to begin with
otherwise you'll regret it you'd be nice
nice and flat and just start peeling
twist you see how thick pif is just
follow with your knife nothing worse
when you're doing this it comes out like
a hexagon or 50 pence piece you can do
this dressing with lemons limes oranges
but there's something quite beautiful
about the pink grapefruit turn it over
and double check a little bit they're
really important to get rid all the pith
and slice each side of your pip that
keeps all those segments together
there's the line it's nice down it's
nice in
give that little stir whisk it starts to
separate all those little segments
season it olive oil
these are little fennel prawns amazing
flavor gives a really nice and seedy
delicious freshness
I've always frustrated me how many
people throw that away because flavor in
there is fantastic and a fish stock
incredibly everything great
next chopped coriander which we say is
served in his marinade something quite
picturesque when you see your work
listening save a little touch of your
dressing for the funnel now your macro
it's being fileted and pin bound rinse
your knife and just slice through
bite-sized chunks ceviche is popular in
Spain and South America is always made
from raw fish or seafood cured in a
citrus dressing the less you handle the
mackerel the better is when you start
mixing up and tossing and turning it you
lose texture the fresh the mackerel is
the better will taste but when you're
serving it raw like this make sure it
really is fresh out of the sea just
lightly seasoned so that ceviche starts
the Cure and marinade and mackerel
finish that with thin little shards of
pink grapefruit and then just a little
drizzle of olive oil on top leave that
to sit I always like marinating my
mackerel literally an hour before I want
to eat it that kind of cured lightly
pickles ceviche flavor that is
incredible
to go with my ceviche for my ultimate
light lunch a beautiful quinoa salad
with amazing textures and fresh aromatic
flavors to excite the palate add one
part pre-rinse quinoa to two parts cold
water if you're not using pre rinse the
quinoa grains should be soaked before
use to remove their bitter coating bring
to a simmer and cook for about 20
minutes until the water is absorbed
bring the cooked quinoa onto a plate and
spread out to cool
meanwhile dry roast flaked almonds in a
frying pan
once golden add raisins
chopped mint and spring onions
[Music]
pihl's strips of skin from a whole
cucumber to make stripes then remove the
seeds and chop into Halfmoon slices
at half cherry tomatoes and the cold
quinoa
and gently mix in with your fingers
[Music]
season with salt and pepper a dress with
a good squeeze of lime and drizzle of
olive oil finish with a few fresh mint
leaves
and for my ultimate light lunch I'm
doing another delicious salad with
shaved fennel the secret here is to peel
the outside I guess with a firm skin it
starts to sort of brighten up a little
bit almost like the sun's come out once
you've discarded the outer layer gently
shave off thin strips of fennel for your
salad the advantage of having this nice
and thin is because it's like these
wonderful thin fennel crisps fragrant
delicious peel them in to your iced
water this can be done a couple of hours
before you want to eat this will
preserve the phenols fresh flavor and
make it lovely and crisp drained the
fennel look at a beautiful complement
the fennel and delicious dressing
starting with chopped coriander fennel
and lime bringing you all together zest
over the fennel and then use all the
goodness inside the lime lightly
seasoned it dressed with the leftover
grapefruit marinade from the ceviche
followed by a drizzle of olive oil
deliciousness mackerel sack marinating
away the beautiful stunning fennel salad
and that goes brilliantly well with a
quinoa packed full of flavor but
incredibly lives and very healthy
no wonder on second
[Music]